after six weeks of campaigning the prime
minister fell foul of this referee on
saturday australians will decide if
scott morrison is fit to keep the
nation's top job
it's a choice between a government that
has a strong economic plan that has
ensured that australia is coming out of
this pandemic stronger than almost any
advanced economy in the world today
the latest poll shows labor just ahead
of the liberal national coalition the
key issues in this election are climate
change the cost of living funding for
aged care and national security these
are all issues that australia has the
opportunity to go forward in and create
a better future if we seize that
opportunity i believe australia is the
greatest country on earth the biggest
challenge for the morrison government is
the rise of female independents there
are 22 high-profile candidates known as
the teals a mix of political movements
seen as blue and green they're funded by
climate group and targeting safe seats
held by the liberal party members i
think there'll be a very high
independent primary vote i think there's
a high level of disillusionment with
major party politics in this country
people are frustrated with one or other
party for various reasons and there's
just become this dynamic that we want
individuals who represent our local
communities nearly six million voters of
an electorate of 17 million have already
cast their ballots through postal or
early in-person voting
i'm very disappointed how close it is
and that it seems there's a lot of
similarities between our two major
parties and i find that quite a
frustrating thing
no there's not much on offer at all
we've gone are the days where we had
statesmen quite frankly we just got a
bickering bunch of children in these you
know politics
if there is no clear majority on
saturday after ballots are counted the
outcome of this election will be a hung
parliament that will mean either labor
or the coalition must make an agreement
with the minor parties or independents
in order to govern
analysts say that prospect is highly
likely i'd be surprised if on saturday
night we know a clear winner from either
the major parties
i think we'll be looking for a count
several days afterwards the polls in
australia open on saturday sarah clark
al jazeera sydney australia